[Applaudissements]
Nathalie comment ça va ma chérie je vais
super bien as-tu trouvé l'amour
non toujours pas est-ce que tu as envie
de trouver l'amour
ah oui j'ai envie de trouver l'amour
bien sûr
oui une fois une fois et ça a duré
combien de temps 15 ans 15 ans ah ouais
donc après tu es parti en cacahuète je
suis parti en cacahuète
après plusieurs déceptions après je me
suis amusé oui
tu as raison ma chérie bien sûr la
gynique ou Mouk à quel moment
à force de me faire je peux pas dire le
mot ah ouais
afin de te faire embrouiller ouais tu en
as eu marre maintenant c'est moi
maintenant
on a rigolé Nathalie c'est une blessure
avec des hommes de mon âge mais ces
hommes là où ils étaient mariés oui
c'était en couple je la prenais toujours
après parce qu'ils sont futés maintenant
je ne jette pas la pierre aux hommes
parce qu'il y a des femmes qui sont
comme ça aussi donc voilà ça c'est voilà
ça s'est fait comme ça tout seul et
après bah oui j'attirai les plus jeunes
et ça a continué au fil des années quoi
mais d'un point de vue mentalité je
m'entends mieux avec les hommes plus
jeunes que moi maintenant ça peut être
aussi cinq six ans plus jeune
je pense à quelqu'un en particulier
parce qu'elle va au contact de la
jeunesse elle fait bouger les choses et
transmettez elle transmet un
savoir-faire de génération génération
c'est presque de la politique ce que
vous faites donc bravo mais je vais pas
prendre des des jeunes de la maison non
plus ça dépend l'âge que j'avais vous
avez snap
je suis surtout les réseaux alors
[Rires]
et après
il est éteint
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ans moi mais non pas du tout elle a dit
que ça peut passer vous voulez revenir
sur ton portrait dans l'émission
regardez
regardez j'ai toujours attiré les plus
jeunes que moi
j'assume
d'aimer et d'attirer des hommes plus
jeunes que moi et de mieux m'entendre
aussi avec eux c'est comme ça
les hommes plus jeunes ou viennent vers
moi parce que souvent on pense pas que
j'ai 48 ans en général on donne 35 dans
la région où j'habite on nous a
confondus avec ma fille ou alors pensez
qu'on était seul plutôt que mère et
fille quoi en fait la des expériences
d'hommes qui nous ont dragués toutes les
deux
peut-être que si j'avais utilisé des
crèmes anti-rides et tout ça serait
peut-être vieilli ma peau là pour
l'instant tout va bien et j'en utilise
même pas
à Nathalie
je t'écoute non mais j'ai l'impression
que tu es bien dans ta tête tu es bien
dans ton corps je suis bien dans tout tu
as envie de te caser ou tu as juste
envie de me casser
avec Adrien
il avait quel âge 30 ans
sans vraiment se parler on a compris
l'un comme l'autre que on peut des très
bons potes ça oui mais pas mais d'un
point de vue sentimental la mentalité
différente
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup bah alors
tu as déstabilisé un peu mais dans
l'émission aussi c'est ton style jean
nON NON MERCI
ce que j'aime j'aime ta franchise
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé que vous étiez extrêmement
sincère et pas lui dire que lui il avait
déjà fait marier au premier regard en
Belgique il était plus dans la
téléréalité vous étiez sincère est-ce
que vous avez senti le décalage tout de
suite avec lui au bout d'un moment oui
j'ai senti le décalage il était là pour
ça il était pas vraiment là j'ai trouvé
pour parce que moi en fait à la base
j'avais flashé sur lui en le voyant à
Marie au premier regard et
on a communiqué c'est pour ça qu'elle
l'a vu donc on a
simplement et on a communiqué pendant
trois mois et puis après je lui ai
proposé qu'on puisse se rencontrer le
pourquoi que je lui ai demandé de se
rencontrer comme ça c'est parce que et
ça c'est vrai quand on propose de voir
via les réseaux
si le mec me plaît je vais dire oui et
après je recule non ah ouais et là si je
m'engagais dans un truc j'étais sûr d'y
aller de le rencontrer ah parce que
souvent toi tu chauffes un peu et après
question de chauffer c'est une question
que j'ai tellement été déçue une fois
non ça m'arrivait trois fois via des
réseaux la première fois je suis passé
du Grand printemps hébreu au petit
groupe Londres
c'est quoi le mec il t'avait dit ouais
c'est un faux profil
des mecs qui qui voulaient s'amuser et
qui faisaient croire autre chose tu n'as
pas envie de t'amuser
de retourner la situation j'ai dit
voulais me s’amuser pas de souci mais
c'est moi qui vais tenir les rênes allez
c'est quoi les
jouets c'est à dire mais le problème
c'est que un jour il y en a qui est
tombé amoureux et là je suis dans la
merde ah ouais tu vois et là j'ai dit je
suis pas faite pour faire ce qu'on fait
non ah ouais parce que toi tu l'aimais
pas non c'est pas le fait que je ne
l'aimais pas je lui avais dit oui on
peut se voir j'ai pas eu à voilà je vais
pas l'envoir 10 je vois quelqu'un je
vois quelqu'un mais j'avais dit
t'attache pas moi je veux plus
d'attachement d'accord
j'étais harcelé quand même pendant trois
mois
j'ai vu qu'il s'attachait j'ai tout
arrêté et après j'aime pas faire du mal
aux gens moi je déteste ça alors tu as
rencontré Adrien au revoir l'extrait où
vraiment tu as tout de suite tapé dans
l’œil
on a senti qu'il y avait un vrai bail
regardez
[Musique]
et toi bon on devait se voir finalement
ça s'est jamais fait maintenant j'avoue
que le cadre est quand même plus sympa
qu'un café enflammé en plein milieu de
la Belgique
ça va tu es pas déçu non non non
physiquement tu me plais je vais pas te
le cacher voilà physiquement tu es mon
style d'homme
à fond
[Rires]
[Musique]
ou pas
déçu que voilà maintenant moi je suis
chouette tout le bonheur du monde
je vais le préciser parce que à l'heure
actuelle harceler et un truc de dingue
mais dans un autre sens et il est en
couple à l'heure actuelle on a rencontré
quelqu'un ouais ça se passe super bien
et j'ai pas envie qu'on pense que parce
que entre lui et moi il s'est rien passé
il y a même pas eu un bisou rien du tout
que
vous allez dormir ensemble moi
on a dormi dans la même chambre oui
alors mais il s'est rien passé
je sais que ça provoque beaucoup de
polémiques c'est genre voilà parce que
vous avez donc sorti les gros moyens
pour charmer Adrien on la revend cette
image c'était très chaud au début moi je
me suis dit ça va se terminer en grippe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime bien les décolletés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu pour l'émission tu es toujours
comme ça je suis tout le temps comme ça
c'est vrai les gens qui me connaissent
très bien savent comment je suis quand
quelqu'un te plaît toi tu fonces
ça dépend ça dépend si je connais déjà
un peu la personne et que je sens que
admettons que je l'ai déjà côtoyé en
tant que potes etc si je vois que je
pourrais m'attacher des fois ça me fait
peur par peur d'être déçus
la personne quoi
je te cache pas carrément
[Rires]
je suis tout le temps comme ça
sortira pas dedans
je laisse le suspense non mais pourquoi
tu vas pas faire l'émission
en premier
chez un homme chez un homme alors
j'aime les hommes qui ont beaucoup
d'humour
[Rires]
tu as défoncé la porte blindée
après quelqu'un qui j'aime bien les
grands ça ouais ça doit physiquement
après d'un point de vue mentalité j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un ça va ouais mais 4
heures
j'ai un problème avec les petits
voilà c'est comme ça c'est bon c'est bon
ça passera humour mes enfants quelques
femmes
ma vie privée on la verra pas sur les
réseaux c'est pour ça que tu as fait les
si on se rencontre
c'est en couple avec Adrien je l'aurais
pas mis sur les réseaux je n'ai rien mis
à la télé alors après vos nombreuses
avances Adrien devraient donc de donner
une réponse est-ce qu'il voulait une
relation sérieuse avec toi regarde
écoute honnêtement des promesses j'ai
pas envie d'en faire parce que ce serait
pas honnête et j'ai pas envie de t'en
faire j'ai pas envie de dire par exemple
je veux jamais d'enfant de ma vie parce
que je ne sais pas par contre ce que je
peux te dire c'est que
je peux rester ici
ce soir avec toi pour qu'on continue à
discuter on verra où
le vent en tout cas ça fait
[Musique]
super
il a rien tenté non absolument pas
tes enfants ils ont quel âge tu as des
enfants de quel âge j'ai les enfants de
25 24 enfin ma fille va bientôt avoir 24
et 22 d'accord ils disent quoi ça les
amuse salut tu fasses des émissions
comme ça non c'est en fait cette parce
qu'il y avait longtemps que je voyais
plus personne et ils m'ont un peu poussé
tu as rien à perdre quoi
si tu peux rencontrer quelqu'un de bien
donc voilà donc ils sont contents
ils ont compris que c'était pas un homme
pour moi ah ouais
et que tu aimes les hommes beaucoup plus
jeunes ils disent quoi ils comprennent
ils s'en foutent que j'aime les hommes
plus jeunes que moi oui mais jusqu'à une
certaine limite ça va prendre un mec de
maintenant je vais pas prendre un mec de
25 ans quoi d'accord mais j'avais dit je
ne descendais plus en dessous de 30 ans
Guillaume
depuis la diffusion de l'émission vous
croulez sous les demandes il y a plein
d'hommes qui sont venus vers vous en
espérant pouvoir vous conquérir
parce que vous avez fait un carton
depuis que l'émission est passé lundi
c'est un carnage
non mais c'est intéressant
il fait des textes ainsi j'en peux plus
je te promets les trucs ça défile sur
mon j'arrive même plus aller lire ton
GSM enfin sur sur les réseaux quoi il me
raconte des trucs comme s'ils me
connaissait depuis toujours oui non
c'est l'image qu'on a vu on voit madame
que vous avez besoin d'affection RFM et
vous êtes prêtes de lire beaucoup
d'affections
[Rires]
sensées parce que vous voyez les femmes
qui arrivent un certain âge qui sont
traumatisés par des divorces douloureux
si vous croyez pas vas-y beaucoup
souffert bah évidemment donc elle a pas
envie de travailler c'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure mais non il faut le
redire la maman c'est pour ça quand je
dis recevras
puisqu'on est dans une émission télé ce
qui parle des médias est-ce que les
hommes jeunes sont des meilleurs coups
que les hommes âgés
pas forcément pas forcément non ça dure
qu'une vieille
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi aussi ça m'a fait plaisir
c'est quand tu veux
j'aime bien parce que Bernard
et voilà et là maintenant voilà c'est
normal on a tous eu des exceptions c'est
moi aussi
crois pas hein
vivre les femmes libérées
[Rires]